welcome to this video for the fourth
round of them Istanbul chess olympiad
again this round um we had some already
rather tight matches in terms of rating
but nevertheless the favorite some
pretty much won all their matches on in
this kind of close match ups let's say
between Germany and Azerbaijan then they
have been draws on France and England
also a 22 at the end so I we all set for
the clashes in round 5 happening today
here set the day the first September on
but lets them and go back to out
yesterday what what happened there I'll
select it um one yeah game finish here
our firm even Chuck's game against the
top board from Poland watershed and the
other game which are we sure income in
its completeness this Nakamura against
Russia Kieran so the US team was playing
in yam ok first this game fragment so if
one shock for Ukraine playing against um
yeah polish top board water check um you
see this position here on new form 32
and tongue it's some pretty messy
position what a shock i'm quite some
months ago and sacrifice the peace corps
two pawns because there had been the
past pants on the queenside which were
very very dangerous so we decided to
better get rid of these pawns for one
piece so we won't show concern is p sub
for two pawns but it's a very young with
messy position as mentioned and why does
sam has used wantage but we see what
what's happening now what I said no
place a sixth attacking the rook and now
he won't show come yeah really found a
very nice solution to this cell to this
problem of this position he sacrificed
the exchange
on b2 took the bishop like recaptured
and now Knight to e5 and this is some
winning a temple on the rook the night
is attacking the rook and yeah the
Rupert doesn't have any good down at
squares or in particularly great stew as
you went to d2 and then here White has a
very nice way to finish the game let's
see Knight f6 check very nice um black
gum took this but let's check briefly
what would happen if you play King a g8
in this position White has the beautiful
move Knight g6 check like needs to take
me h6 check if it takes and zouk h7
which is one of my favorite sector
meeting a pattern so I simply love this
knight on f6 book on h7 King on a trade
so it's a very nice double sacrifices
night g6 check and the Queen Queen Zack
very nice so this would happen if him
like would move the king zoe we saw it
took it and now we want to skip this
check like now goes to h7 wide can take
here and i think this service actually
what's the game right sorry this
actually was the game um with the
following made to happen and it's a very
nice checkmate again and if like would
would go here then we have this one
check takes and look check here now
black him and through computer star skip
all these books and at the end its Queen
g8 mate so on let's recap this quickly
good night at six wife is winning King
h8 here to this nice
nigeria sec yeah and this led to to
checkmate as well so um yeah very nice
finish here for von schook who seems to
have fun recovered from his rather
unlucky Lawson I think it was wrong to
against them against Iran was it Iran um
I'm not sure against armada hiki no this
is kurt arrives this is Katara sorry um
yeah okay so even shook with a win
against for tasha and ukraine also won
the match sure i think 3 2 1 i'm not
mistaken they want it yeah they want
right poland scotland on for bat-turn 31
at the end ok so let's now switch to the
the main game which is ok me to find it
here which is here Nakamura against asha
kiran from India US team team was
playing India and let's see what
happened so Carol played before and that
she currently five yeah I think he's 31
mainly plays ePHI for all the night off
so this was an expected answer might
have 396 and now the Scotch game which
my camera placed from time to time he
plays all kinds of opening so it's hard
to tell what's really this kind of main
weapon ok we get them get the scotch and
asha kiran opts for Knight f6 here black
has a couple of alternatives obviously
the main alternative being Bishop c5 in
my repertoire serious and I recommend
this check which is maybe slightly worse
than the other moves but still very much
playable and it puts right off a bit of
the beaten track ok but logic Iran
played m96 after which lie camera 2.6
the so called me this variation called
after someone think german player from
the 19th century
so 96 e c6 and c5 this is the line which
has been popularized by by Kasparov and
the 90s when he suddenly played the
scotch and the World Championship match
which was really a bit of a sensation at
the time as basically everyone was
playing the ruler pass and no one was
playing the Scotch so I cop offers
really am surprised them them but it
became into fashion afterwards and it's
still a viable alternative to Tordrillo
pass or the Italian game okay queenie 7
this is really necessary move um gap
probably necessary move it looks ugly of
course but this attack on on the pawn
pretty much flawless white sleep like we
need to you cannot really n play
something like I know f4 and get your
Center broken up so quickly so on
Queenie to heavens now the mud obviously
is hanging so it needs to move and now
see form attacking the the knight on d5
yeah here black has two moves really you
can play Bishop a6 you delight in this
pin here to keep the knight on d5 for
Lulu a little longer on the other hand
this Bishop might be misplaced in the
long run because it detects c4 but very
often why just covers it and it's um
it's but it's very concrete this kind of
opening it's not like you could play
this on general considerations it's very
much fun metal calculation concrete
concrete lines there's a Kirin plate 96
immediately which is some perfectly okay
then the other main move 93 and now
Bishop d7 this move was them a bit of an
obscure line until I think 2011 when
Kramnik played it to win quickly against
shear off in NY cans a cattle co or
chorus at the time I think
yeah Bishop d7 the ideas to quickly get
to to the Queen side with a king and
then probably break up the center um i'm
not a huge expert on this so i cannot
really tell when the novelty assets in I
mean I found games Bishop f4 has been
played castles castles long g5 all this
has been played but on in relatively low
level games and I have my notebook here
on vacation I don't have my big database
where could maybe look at very very new
game so probably it's possible that i
miss some some game okay g5 looks a bit
yeah a bit exotic at falls maybe but the
ideas when a temple on the bishop and
then in this kind of configuration you
have Bishop g7 and you put pressure on
this pawn and g5 also means that any
kind of covering by a pawn can be taken
so legs ideas to pressurizes e5 pawn so
why played h1 ok he needed to attend to
this age for thread winning a piece
g-form yam and now on this had been
played before I think in one game they
have had been played down and I'll King
me one this was also this game that I
thought I saw now Queen III was yeah was
a new move but i'm i'm not sure that
them i guess they they they are on their
own now if you look at the clock time
some both had spent about half an hour
need to take into account at the bonus
30 seconds so on yeah how to assess this
position it's um actually very difficult
I must say um I always find out this
kind of positions very hard to to
evaluate as it's very uneven black hands
got some wood we had pieces on the
queenside and yeah white has got this
pawn which might be a possible weakness
but also restricts blacks possibilities
at the moment and also black has the
potentially
problematic king not at the moment he's
got those pieces which also marked in
red here helping form for any possible
attacks but in the long term this king
cat can be a problem with those pawns
and I was very red okay young so very
young very difficult position to assess
let's see what happens black playgroup
de eight which is DF fairly logical i
would say checking v5 and a camera play
droopy one covering this tag pawn a knob
black plate c5 yeah this all seems very
understandable to me wants to get this
Bishop into play and I think I'd would
assess his position as around eco I can
I don't think that black has some any
big big problems here he has pretty
healthy pieces this night on b6 is not
doing so much at the Texas before but
that's it but black seems to be fairly
okay i would say okay like i'm gonna
place them and yet typically sharp move
forth i played a form directly trying to
attack this night and okay black needs
to do something about this you cannot
really allow on the night to being
pushed back to 22 a8 so on black needs
to react in a way and he did this with
d6 i also had a brief look at them the
possible continuation 85 which might
look a bit weird because this powerless
a bit yeah i would he call it it's a bit
bit alone it's not protected by anyone
and just imagine white would get a queen
here it would be a very nice you cannot
cover the spawn and i'm not sure um this
really a big problem let's say why would
play Queen d2 it's a d6 not be five you
should take the g5 queen here Queenie
7.net it doesn't look too bad to me but
a five is a very haver is very
strange-looking move and it's it was
necessary
what does Shakira unplayed was perfectly
all right he played d6 attacking the
center makes much sense to me Nona come
up at a 59 to d7 and night b5 so very
concrete play on the a7 pond what
happened now ok night XD five black wrap
the pawn so he won this pawn on d5 which
he had put so much pressure on and now
on what's what happens next why played
the interesting move queen bee three and
then this is a thang a very critical
position for this game as here black
could have played them paid differently
really he played on Bishop to a 8 which
makes sense in a way because um he wants
to get his King in the center after
night takes a 7 and the bishop on b7 was
a liability down and i want to show you
an alternative and this is just form
yeah i'm just for showing what's what's
possible um but then it's very
understandable that black didn't play it
you also must see he really was a look
at the clock times like a more hour 40
minutes shashi kiran 18 he really was
down on time already so he played this
but the alternative that i want to
mention is this move which at first
looks like complete nonsense because of
this check if you look at this King
assume this is checked and if he goes to
the center you just pick this and it's
over so black needs to go here and then
your first instant is all right okay
just take here and next move our play in
96 and win the Queen but black has the
amazing resource 27 you can just play
play this funny move and this night
cannot escape and strangely
if you look at this wise we might take
and retreat the night blackwood would
simply take and play something like this
auntie this is even even better for
black but this is of course very
difficult to to calculate or even
consider them it's a very unnatural kind
of way of playing but then it's a bit of
a typical computer line what is also I'm
interesting in this position if you look
look at this year group takes d5 is one
idea but also you can ask what about
this move yeah black needs to take it
otherwise the queen is lost by the night
who needs to take take here and rick
cakes and this is an interesting
position where black has sacrificed the
Queen for Rick miler piece I'm pawn and
hype like itself is almost winning in
this position because his pieces are so
you are beautifully coordinated um this
one is coming possibly efficiently for
check it's a it's dreadful really a
terrible position for what the computer
already has this as minus for us or what
will we lose instantly basically a six
months was an interesting idea which am
at the end might be really unclear right
can also play in this position after a
six on this business another way white
could also play rook takes in five by
the way which is an idea the idea being
after Bishop b5 mouse with this check
and even this kind of position isn't
isn't completely clear like mine might
have a dislike this end the night here
delano it's very much very much
difficult um black am can also after
route takes d5 so we have a six which
you would Gucci this statistic played in
the game we have a six oops let's move
let me show this briefly again Luke
takes d5 after this black even has the
funny resource which should be for check
and this also ends in about an equal
position as Sri a 6 was was a
possibility but okay with little time he
played Bishop a 8 it's not real mistake
no mistake it's a perfectly all right
can do this so now I played f form and
this is a good move i think it detects
the night and floss is black to capture
on pants off and here White has given
himself an additional possibility of
giving a check on h3 so white just them
got extra options with F form very good
very good idea so here Queen f6 which is
also a thing perfectly alright we
activates the Queen and the steps out of
this this pin obviously ok right now
trapped on a 7 and King GA yo you cannot
go to d7 because of this this check
immediately so King the aid and yeah
this position is really really
complicated and you need to take into
account the crop times the jakhira an
awesome on about 15 minutes left and my
camera had about 30 minutes and yeah
obviously he's a very good um yeah
technician who can set problems he now
gave him and I so sorry he took it too
gaudy 5 and now the check and yeah what
should like doing he must really am go
here if you would go to e7 and why just
just takes him so here and now just
mentioned idea Bishop h3 check and yeah
black has no no big choice it needs to
interpose with the rook and it's not
such a big deal that like loses exchange
white girl gives a check king here and
now it took took the exchange
it's not such a big deal because of the
concrete features of the positions are
more important black cam has some this
nice Bishop which might grab a pawn he's
gotten the diagonal to work and the
Snider's isn't so great either it's a
it's still a very tricky position
probably um in in computer terms so it's
it's fine for a while but it's very
difficult to play now can we run our
play group g1 and we see that he caught
up on the clock if this is correct ya
hear black head route d8 which looks um
looks normal really I'm centralizing
this service piece and he also really
could have considered to take here but
this is the typical cold-blooded
computer move that you get suggested all
the time and made me a person a human
would wouldn't really think about
growing pawns but it's probably possible
something like this is the main line
ended engine and in an unclear position
maybe still slightly better for white
because of black skin that you could
continue this for a while it's a very
difficult to assess okay he didn't take
it he played down oops you played this
this route move and here my camera I
think I'm could have could have played
better but this is also a typical
computer move he played 96 which is
perfectly perfectly alright I think also
the move I would would have considered
really but then computer says group g2
is very strong and okay one idea is to
protect this pawn from the side and the
other is to utilize the ribs here
doubling or possibly even doubling on e2
yeah this looks funny so white can use
as looks very flexibly and this is some
very huge advantage according to the
computer but
alright and so at least that's it
difficult to find this new ninety six or
seven seven is the human move here which
after takes takes on g7 just returning
the exchange leads to this position and
this is the kind of position of you if
you look at this no it's a simple line
to calculate which is simply COK White
has chances with this a pawn and black
has a little problem to coordinate again
to spawn and you still have this play
against the king so this is the position
you can just simply assess as being
somewhat better for you and the other
position is slim rocky with rook g2 so
this is really the human decision yeah
and then this position um there's a key
role played Queen to b4 note that
they're down to two or three two minutes
or six minutes and whites case so on
it's really a yeah it's a bit of a blitz
game now but note that they get 30
seconds pen moves that's not done it's
not that bad okay I'm queen before the
end intelligence you also could could
cook JD's furnaces but okay Queen before
is a very understandable move you want
to centralize two pieces and then
especially if you've got not so much
time on the clock here you should try to
maximize your piece activity a6 pushing
the pawn and now we gave this check and
Queenie to attacking the robot until I
come up late Queen reform yeah who King
to d7 very cold blooded white could
could take now on on on ace only six and
this is in fact a very critical position
here instead of a seven Nakamura played
and what actually should have taken only
six but it's difficult kinsa 60cm
removed now this
black needs to go back otherwise you
cannot go here because of this year
leaving to mate so I mean sue needs to
go back and and only in this position a
seven and this is much better than the
game that would lead to something like
this we need five czech teen be one
Queen e7 with e seven check Kim's e8
check here and then Ruby three and why
this is better black hands go fight but
right is certainly better because the
King has some just a huge problem in the
game la cámara played a seven so sort of
the other way around but this game where
does the QR no chance which she knew she
didn't took he M played he could have
played Queen 85 check can be one and
rook e8 and this is actually ok for
black it's a it's simply not possible to
keep this pawn what can try all kinds of
things which look really dangerous i
must admit let's say to play this one
you can take here yeah and now black can
simply interpose i think even this one
is playable funny enough um yeah it
looks very dangerous for black but it
seems to be playable so maybe he didn't
really appreciate this simple rule
piayed often this simple moves are are
the most difficult one simply covering
this actually what he did wasn't so bad
either he played the move Luke a eight
the far more complicated choice and
checking the pawn and and this this of
course is no problem i don't exactly
stir no no it's not at least disap
apparel check but i cannot do anything
more so why tell what didn't take when
nakamura did was um he played the move
TV one and this is really a clever move
really close now black had about four
minutes on the clock if you can trust
the clock times and what you should have
done now is so II fight and in fact
after you five he is perfectly ok it
says all very cool planet to to play
this the point is why plays group g1
intending so text black and really
simply take here as this is okay for
black but it's a something yeah it's
difficult to assess this kind of
position if you've got only a couple of
minutes on the clock the real problem is
that white doesn't have them any time
from ya form four moves that are not a
check here for silent moves so to say
cannot play something like this with
this thread because it's It's Made made
on the other side so on this is the real
problem like has a big counter play
going and why can give all kinds of
checks but it's simply no checkmate look
at this you're just you're just escaping
it's a draw but you're just escaping but
okay back back to the the game position
after Nakamura played this this trap him
move King one yeah here's a chic you on
yeah he took on a seven yeah and
disinfect after taking what should like
do king v8 is a simple made in one so he
needs to go here and now after after
this move what should like do this is
just made in one so needs to go here
Queen B 5 check King anywhere Andrew P a
check yeah and this is how it ended he
he took a seven end after effect after
this Queenie a check and there's a queue
are designed and view of the
upcoming made so actually I think he did
a tremendous job keeping this position
together with his shaky king but he
really fell just a three moves short of
the time control I wonder if the town
clock chimes I really correct because I
think with four minutes on the clock he
should spot them up the major really but
then he was under so much pressure on
times and that at one point here you
might correct this is simply the the
candle phone play that is very much
typical of the top players that they
keep on setting the opponent problems
putting pressure on various on various
points and at some point you mind simply
make a blunder because here you're not
able to cope with the pressure anymore
so on it ended in a check made following
following this yeah this was so in fact
the only win for the US team against the
India they played a 2-2 tie as gotta
come steal us to I think it was hari
krishna on board too um and um yeah I
hope you enjoyed this game with their
it's a very typical fighting fighting
game of her typical of today's
complicated technical chest and another
game that is interesting to look at
especially for the finish this Grisha
come again and with black against value
air from the match Russian world's china
yesterday I didn't cover tienda video
because it has been covered by other
commentators I think Andrew Martin and
then your king they both did a video on
this so if you want to watch this game
run um against crucial check out the
Denny Kings channel or Andrew Martin's
um maybe that's even another version of
it but okay I didn't want to do this um
this game also to not have so many yeah
repeats so to say that you've got the
same game all the time yeah thanks for
watching